[Music]
Star Trek beyond will mark the 50th
anniversary of the Star Trek franchise
the five decades that that Star Trek has
been with us and yet at the time when it
was created it did the unthinkable et
was on set with the cast and they told
us how they'll pay tribute to the 60s TV
series starting with the uniform the new
uniforms clearly shoulder pads are back
in it's a little retro which I really
like yeah it's I mean it's just in the
50th anniversary with you know the
designers have done a wonderful job of
you know giving a lovely known to Star
Trek the past I think everybody behind
the scenes you know wanted to pay real
true homage to the sixties birth of this
series so I think it has that kind of
throwback plate but this is the first
Star Trek since the passing of Leonard
Nimoy are you guys thinking of any
tribute to yeah I mean I think it's
perhaps the foam itself is kind of
tributed enough it'll be the 50th
anniversary coming up when the film is
released and it's a big thing you know
Leonard was a special special man his I
think his spirit has infused this you
know at this incarnation from the
beginning from the first film that we
miss him dearly and wish she could be a
part of this but you know we know he's
in a in a good place